có việc tưởng hôm nay thì mối bất động sản sẽ được tập một mắt định dành dịch từ giống.
Cuy định tại nghiệp về xây dựng và quản lý hệ thống thông tin cơ sở giữ liệu với nhà ở và thiệt trường bất động sản.
Mắt định dành dịch từ bất động sản là chuẩn bị tượng gồm chứ và số tối ra là cũng mối tượng.
Được cấp dân, cho mối cân nhà, các hộ chung cư dân này, hộ bất động sản trong công trình xây dựng.
Mắt định dành được cấu thành từ cơ thông tin cơ bản như là mắt thử đất, mắt dự ăn, mắt công trình.
Mắt định điểm, quá trình cơ má được thực hiện tức đậm trên hệ thống.
Mắt này được liên thông với các rữ liệu với quyền sự giúp đất, cuối hại, lịch sự giáo dịch,
tình trạm thế chấp và hế vụ tài trình.
Sở xây dựng đánh má trơn nhà ở gồm ca giữ án trên đệ bản.
Hế thống rất liệu được xây dựng thông bởi lịch thông bảo đầm cân nối, chia sẻ về các cơ sở rữ liệu của ra chánh trường lập.
Bản bộ rữ liệu là tài sản dành hước, gió bộ xây dân quản lý và được bảo vệ nghiêm hạn.
Cũng cụ hôm nay thì giáo dịch bất đậm sản sẽ phải đăng ký và cập nhật theo mạc số,
các quan khỏe li có thể theo gió xác hơn giá trị trình nhớm thực tế theo tình hú vực, tương loại hình.
Nên hàng có thể xác mình lịch sự giáo dịch và tình trạm phóc lý ngàn hơn.
Bị trình hoa rất liệu và lịch dành tài sản, giúp tăng tường kỳ lợt, lệ tị trường bất đậm sản Việt Nam tiếp cận thông lệ của tế.